ce soir notre performance sera assurée
par roland menou qui fait son one man
show au théâtre des blancs manteaux dans
une mise en scène c'est écrit en tout
petit de david de l'attention bonsoir
alors ce spectacle hors vais je me suis
fait remarquer là vous êtes surveillés
par un an j'ai vu mais sans tourner le
dos pour l'un d'eux m'a écouté il suffit
que demandé voilà parce que votre
spectacle alors on va voir l'allusion
votre spectacle a été écrit par vous et
par audrey tautou est donc le nain est
censée symboliser audrey tautou
non il n'est pas très grande non non pas
des toutous mais amélie poulain tel il
ya une hôtesse de l'air et vous allez
voir qu'on va en venir votre spectacle
une hôtesse de l'air qui promène 1 1
dans le monde entier et envoie des
photos et dans votre spectacle il y à
une hôtesse de l'air puisque votre
spectacle
on va le résumer ainsi il y a six
personnages qui sont en relation avec
une compagnie 5ce hermes a bien prononcé
à bien prononcer voilà et dans lequel il
ya une hôtesse de l'air un petit peu
particulières sont au moins déjà un des
personnages
c'est une hôtesse de l'air qui s'appelle
françoise qui est sous sous sous sous
sous chef de cabine et qui galère un peu
parce qu'en fait elles ne sont que deux
dans l'avion et donc à son sens et à ses
obligés de changer de coiffure et des
postiches avec des postiches pour se
faire pour sa croix à la clientèle
qu'elles sont plusieurs
on voit un petit peu à l'esprit de vos
spectacles donc c'est une galerie de
personnages à l'orias père patrice qui
est l'assistant personnel du pack pas
alors il y adapter mais en fait on avait
envie avec audrey d'écrire un truc sur
la célébrité et en fait on a imaginé que
le pape devait avoir le même staff que
celui de
de madonna et roselyne lancé la soeur
d'une grosse machine ça c'est
l'accessoire de roselyne un peu les
rouges lille en fait telle affaire d'une
gamme chanteuse québécoise qui est très
connu dans le monde entier
c'est cette fille qui à qui elle n'a pas
la carrière de chasseurs en même temps
et du coup elle est la casse un peu
d'aigreur et a dit c'est pas ça là
patatrac sous l appât tam tams ou d'un
sens où elle tire énormément sur
l'accord cadre
et je me dis un jour ça va péter voilà
les un peu dans l'aigreur comme ça et
voilà
rolland jeune comédien qui a fait 9
jeunes comédiens qui se retrouvent à
tourner avec catherine deneuve ville va
planter là celle ci en même temps il est
très heureux du parler il a dû tout pas
du tout pas à madame de 9 du décret
comme ça il a les mots ne sortent pas et
cette jeune fille qui lancent des
baguettes en l'air là d'où elle vient
celle ci l on la voit dans un premier
temps en défilé où là elle est plus
comme ça check et ses filles et après on
la voit un peu bourré andy dans la salle
des fêtes en discours à la mairie où
elle remercie les gens des septs est ce
qu'on va moins ça va devoir sylvie
maintenant voilà après sur des filets
bon eh bien écoutez le sur les i alors
nous allons écouter
roland menou qui va vous faire découvrir
sylvie qui est une majorette du côté de
castelnaudary d'aller voir bien on
écoute
roland venir est tout sauf une petite
démonstration est d'abord une petite
démonstration de bâton alors vous voyez
il ya cinq ans je vais faire mon
discours alors je rejoins le bateau dans
le sac abattoirs et c'est un peu
compliqué voilà corinthians tu peux vous
donner la coupe de champagne
merci corinne était sur le coup c'est
très bien alors bon voilà je joue au
ping-pong une petit bar avant d'y aller
monsieur le maire monsieur l'adjoint au
maire messieurs les conseillers
tout d'abord merci merci de votre
accueil et merci de la confiance que
vous avez accordé une fois de plus à mon
équipe de majorettes
l'équipe des comètes que vous dire de
plus si ce n'est la fierté que nous
avons eues mois et les filles d'escorter
une fois de plus la reine du muguet qui
cette année n'a pas su c'est la tour
eiffel pour la dhr pointu mais on peut
l'applaudir elle est très mignonne on
l'applaudît n'avions pourtant
et pourtant monsieur le maire quelques
requêtes
vous n'êtes pas sans ignorer monsieur le
maire que l'équipe des comètes n'a pas
changé de body depuis deux ans mon
compte de collants photo heureusement
forte heureusement nous avons pu faire
cette année ressemeler les bottines à
l'antidérapage éviter les accidents beau
à propos d'accidents une bonne fois pour
toutes
n'est t'il vraiment pas possible que
l'équipe des comètes précède le poney
club plutôt que de slalomer entre les
merdes du cul du cul andré andré andré
écoute moi nous pouvons trouver un
terrain d'entente car je pensais que la
malheureuse glissade de geneviève
interpellé bon on en reparlera backstage
voilà il est fort ressemble pas c'est
parce que le verre est bébé bien merci
le maire merci l'adjoint au paquet
pendant pas docteur j'vais pas à écouter
vous le savez bien que vous êtes bien
membré l'a toujours avec le dinovo
lalinde groupe actes n'ont pas donc
et merci pour ce [ __ ] de buffet qui
j'en suis sûr va bien nous régaler
corinne attention à ta culotte de cheval
sinon l'année prochaine tu défilent avec
les poneys de du cul merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]